u.s. president elect Donald Trump has
sacked the son of his choice for
national security advisor from his
transition team for spreading false news
Michael Flynn jr. tweeted a fake story
about a pedophile ring in Washington
which resulted in an armed standoff in a
pizza restaurant here's our US
correspondent Amanda Walker comet pizza
a popular Washington DC neighborhood
restaurant unwittingly at the center of
a deeply troubling internet storm last
weekend as people were dining inside
here a 28-year old man turned up armed
with an assault rifle - as he put it
self investigate what police have called
a fictitious online conspiracy theory
the man fired a shot inside the
restaurant no one was hurt but this
became an alarming consequence of a
growing online phenomena fake news so I
think we're definitely on to something
here with this pizza gate investigation
this stemmed from a bizarre and
completely false article claiming that
Hillary Clinton was running a child sex
ring out of the pizzeria one of the more
high-profile figures fanning the flames
of the spurious story was Michael G
Flynn the son of retired General Michael
T Flynn who president elect Donald Trump
has tapped to be his national security
adviser after the attack Flynn jr.
tweeted that the story had not been
proved untrue following this tweet he's
no longer working for Trump's transition
team but the president-elect swore on
the establishment has created a climate
for such theories that could come back
to haunt him he has loosed onto the
scene a an openness to volatile and
exotic ideas and it will be interesting
to see how he tries to rein that in when
he needs people to believe him other
businesses like the politics and prose
bookstore on the same block as comic
pizza have been tied to the false
reports staff here have been receiving
threatening phone calls they came from
untraceable numbers and
just sort of talking about saying you
know they knew what was going on and
they were going to come and they were
going to do terrible things sort of
making these wild to coming up with
these wild theories about underground
tunnels linking our businesses and and
much much worse all of the affected
businesses have been comforted by the
Solidarity shown by their customers but
after Sunday's shooting incidents there
now watching more closely who comes
through their doors the area now has
police protection as long as these lies
dressed as fact can be disseminated
freely on the Internet there's an
unsettling sense that this could happen
again with more devastating consequences
Amanda Walker's Sky News Washington
well joining me now is Alan Moses who is
chairman of the independent press
regulator if so welcome to you now
obviously a you're not responsible for
what goes on in America but this is nor
responsible for what's on that what's on
the interval exactly but that's what
that's what I was going to ask you
because some of those stories do end up
in the mainstream media obviously you
could say it's bad journalism but we've
all picked things up and been victims in
there been victims of it what can be
done about it well I think that the most
important thing is that people should
realize that something does need to be
done if a newspaper gets a full story
from a full source and this has happened
then of course it is within it says
jurisdiction and if it's that the
newspaper will be responsible for
publishing that inaccurate full story
but it's a much wider and important
problem and a really important problem
in this country because people's voices
and people's votes depends upon making a
judgement on accurate information and if
a post truth becomes acceptable and
something is not I mean you say you're
not responsible for what people say on
the internet but the Internet is there
it is a source of information which most
people most people get their news from
out exactly most people get their news
for so would you like to have your
powers extended
could that even be done would that be
practical I'm sure it needs to be
thought about and it is practicable and
I don't believe it should just be left
of Facebook or to the organizations they
have just formed a partnership for the
benefit of society in September 2016
there's a council a British government
have created the Council for data ethics
in April 2016 and it is something until
it's grappled with press regulation is
merely a small part of really what is
far more important that is the
regulation of information because
people's votes and democracy depends
upon accuracy on which they based it is
one of these things which crosses
borders I mean we know for example that
a lot of the anti Harry Clinton stories
were actually emanating from Eastern
Europe people generating so he's
clickbait and so dangerous and of course
in in the United States where you have
the First Amendment where no regulation
of news and journalism is possible so
how can it be dealt with well it needs
to be dealt with by look I mean people
are looking into it I'm not going to be
able to give a coherent answer but it
can be dealt with by looking at the
sources looking at the servers looking
at the way in which and those
responsible for dissemination the public
don't even know about it when you think
that the news that you get from
something like Facebook all judged by
algorithms the like of which and the
nature of which we simply don't even
understand I mean do they all change
their position Facebook has changes
position on face news or fake news on
new streams but again a lot of people
going to say well that's just you know
that's the establishment ganging up
stopping me reading what I wanted that's
the trouble because nobody ever promised
that the truth would be interesting and
the really danger is that post truth
which is the oxford dictionaries
favorite word for 2016 will become
acceptable and it's up to all of us and
the public and the readers to say that
we wish to distinguish between
newspapers that have editors and have
journalists and
the regulator episode that regulates
them and this sort of flatulence on the
on the Internet you you are the head of
ipso which is the newspaper supported
supported by many of the main newspapers
regulator not the government sanctioned
body impress which which was set up but
you see the problem is some people will
look at things like for example that
headline of the Daily Mail one of the
strongest supporters of it so calling
judges enemies of the people and trying
to dig into their private life and say
well that's just the sort of thing which
we don't like and glad that they don't
like it I'm not going to give a running
commentary on matters because it sits
before us at the moment but it might be
worth considering the difference in that
one sentence that you put me between
saying enemies of the people which is an
opinion and the intrusion into private
life which is quite clearly potentially
a breach in the black well I mean corner
measures of people but also going into
their backgrounds what their connections
are to Europe implying that that will
somehow bias their impartial judgment is
more than it so we'll have to give a
judgement about that and we'll do say a
judgement in which I won't take part
because I know them well and therefore
feel we know both sides very yes and
what would happen I mean if you decided
that that I mean for example I know you
haven't decided but if you've just that
headlines gone out it's gone around the
world what can you do about we do what
we always do when we find a breach of
the editors code we require the
publication to correct it publish it in
the place that we dictate in the words
that we dictate and with the font size
we dictate so you could have a reverse
front page saying not enemies of the
people or something like that you could
sure that would be very good journalism
do you think if so has made a difference
to the behavior of the news and quite
quite to certain it has and I wouldn't
be going on doing this if I didn't
believe it has I believe internally in
newspapers they really are taking it far
more seriously in the processes and the
thought processes they go through before
they publish a story and I think they
hate the fact that when we do find
a breach and require them to correct it
there is a lot of argument before we
reach a judgment but it's our judgment
that counts and they respect that and I
do think that if you talk to them and if
you read pilling the independent report
that we have obtained you will see that
they do take it seriously yes there is
still though the threat of these
punitive damages or under Section four
2040s newspapers don't join up to the
government the sanction you know it's a
body what do you think should be done
about that well I mean there's a
consultation and the newspapers are very
good at explaining the chilling effect
of not indulging in any investigative
journalism if there's a fear of being
involved in compulsory arbitration or in
litigation and giving a free ride to the
claimants from a regulators point of
view what is really important I believe
is the contractual consent by which the
newspapers have been persuaded to sign
up to us and if you wave a stick at them
if you beat them into a
government-backed position it will make
regulation far harder and that'll be far
more serious from the public do you
think newspapers are dying anyway I
don't think they are I think they're in
great difficulties but I do want to say
as the regulator that you and I will
suffer without newspapers members of the
public will suffer the way we read
edited journalism is totally different
from the vacuity on on the internet it
even if we read it online the way it is
written and the way it is absorbed is
different and is important I mean you
may not you you're much too young but I
come from a generation when it was
wonderful to with marmalade all over all
over the second page or whatever and and
and the smell of it and the serendipity
of being able to read five articles at
the same time and the picture do you
think they don't anymore when they can
get so much at the particular few
buttons on I think there's a real
problem of what I hate that word' the
Millennials I mean I don't think my
children read them in the same
way as as you and I but I think they
will continue to do so and the more the
the vapid nonsense spread on the
Internet is spread the more people will
look back to and look for newspaper job
I think we can both agree to that hope
thank you very much a detail and Moses
the jolliest
thank you very much